[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
dear guests
the prime minister of Iceland
[Music]
distinguished colleagues dear guests a
it's a pleasure and a privilege to
welcome you to Iceland to the Reykjavik
Summit of the Council of Europe
foreign
and it is to that core mission that the
Parliamentary assembly the European core
of Human Rights the Congress of local
and Regional authorities the missions in
Strasbourg and the secretariats and our
institutions and missions are dedicated
however we are not gathered here in
celebration but under the clouds of War
Russia's aggression against Ukraine is
the gravest assault on peace and
Security in Europe since since the
second world war in addition to huge
military casualties it has led to
massacres rapes and murders of civilians
to the people of Ukraine and to
president silenski I want to say this
we have tremendous respect for your
determination to resist and we will
continue to stand with you and to call
on Russia to withdraw its forces from
Ukraine as the first steps towards
ending this war
we also demand accountability and adjust
peace the victims of this war have a
right to be heard and not to be
subjected to Oblivion
this senseless war in our continent is
contrary to all the values for which we
United with the founding of this Council
it's a grave assault on the very
principles that make Europe more than
just a continent for the common cause
dear colleagues in recent years we have
witnessed increasing political attempts
to undermine basic values subvert
Democratic democratic practices and
weaken the rule of law
democracy has come under strained due to
various forms of authoritarian
encroachments and we are facing a
widespread and violent pushback against
women's rights and freedoms gender
equality and lgbti rights
we should not forget that the Democratic
concept that underpins the European
convention on human rights and the
European social Charter is inclusive it
requires that the rights and interests
of all are considered including those
most vulnerable to violations of their
basic rights
the very concept of human rights for
everyone continues to be contested and
without firm resistance hard-earned
rights can disappear in an instant or
wither away in silence
it's also a reminder that a democratic
political system is not a given it can
survive only if it's embedded in a
society that allows it to prosper
the Reykjavik Summit has three main
objectives first to reaffirm our support
for Ukraine to adopt concrete measures
to address accountability for war crimes
and to strengthen the Council of
Europe's role as a leading human rights
organization
second to renew in general terms our
commitment to the Democratic human
rights values that our societies are
based on and that must be nurtured and
protected
and lastly by recommitting to our values
we seek to meet pressing Global
challenges
the climate and the biodiversity crisis
is affecting all parts of the world with
Rising temperatures fueling natural
disasters food and water insecurity
economic disruptions and Wars
the exponential growth of artificial
intelligence raises profound questions
about its detrimental as well as its
beneficial effects about the nature of
knowledge production control of
information and ultimately its influence
on democracy
we have a duty to make this Gathering a
meaningful undertaking we are here to
discuss problems that need urgent action
and let us make the most of this
opportunity to conclude I hope that the
Reykjavik Summit will be remembered as
an event when European leaders stood in
solidarity with Ukraine as well as a
venue for reaffirming core values in a
time of war and Democratic backsliding
to ensure that our common costs Europe
will be able to meet the enormous
challenges ahead
and with these words I declare the
Reykjavik Summit of the Council of
Europe formally open
and now it's my great honor to introduce
the next speaker who is joining us
online from Kiev president zelenski you
have the floor
thank you
thank you so much
prime minister yeah Dr Catherine
thank you for invitation to participate
in the summit of our Council of Europe
and for your sincere desire to help you
train
dear leaders of Europe
today Ukraine went through a difficult
challenge
and then tells Russian missile attack
such challenges are what we all have to
pay attention to now
at three o'clock in the morning our
people woke up to explosions 18 Russian
missiles of different types were in our
sky in particular ballistic ones which
the terrorist state has boasted
about where we are told
such missiles would bring a guaranteed
task because they are supposedly
impossible to shut down
Russia used ballistics cruise missiles
drones at the same time to make it
especially difficult for our defense to
save lives but all lives were protected
all missiles were shut down
including ballistic ones
100 percent
this is a historical result
thank you all
Russia
is trying very hard to improve its
ability to kill
we are trying very hard to improve the
protection of our people and I thank all
the countries and leaders who help us to
improve our air defense
all together we are showing what our 100
men
and what the power of the Free World
means
and of course I think every our soldier
who makes this job done in our skies
and on a land and especially I think
each and every who trains our Warriors
in different train missions which are
all similar in one point in success
thanks to all of them thanks to all of
you
a year ago we were not able to shoot
down most of the terrorists missiles
especially ballistic ones and I'm asking
one thing now
if we are able to do this is there
anything we come to when we are united
and determined to protect lives the
answer is that we in unity will give 100
in any field
when we have a goal to protect our
people and our Europe and of course
there is still much to be done
Ukraine's territory is big and to make
air defense results like last night's
the rule throughout the country we need
additional air defense systems and miss
us we also need more than 500 Jets
without which no air defense system will
be perfect and I'm sure we will get
there 100 should be our Benchmark we
must live zero percent to the aggressor
100 of success of Defense operations is
guaranteed by weapons and training of
our soldiers and I thank everyone who
strengthens our defense 100 of success
of sanctions is guaranteed by honesty in
every state honestly and I'm grateful to
all those who threat The Fight Against
Terror in this way honestly
100 of success of our peace formula is
guaranteed by diplomacy and I thank
everyone who helps us unite the world to
implement the peace formula the only
realistic peace plan and of course 100
of Justice
and there will be no reliable peace
without Justice and I think the castle
of Europe each and every of you
personally for the decision of the
register of damages caused by Russia's
depression this brings closer the
creation of a full-fledged compensation
mechanism that will show the role that
aggression is not worse even thinking
about
there should also be a special Tribunal
for the crime of aggression so the deuce
whose Heads This Terror was born in are
brought to responsibility and I'm sure
that we will provide this result for 100
percent
Europe has been waiting for such times
time spent leaders who would act in 100
unity and with 100 results for the sake
of protecting Europe for the sake of our
common values and finally this is what
we are achieving now
Ukraine all of Europe and everyone who
is currently at this Summit and who
helps us we are Europeans so we are free
we are Europeans so we value peace we
are Europeans so we act at 100 of our
strengths when it comes to protecting
our way of life
let this be forever the rules of our
continent
thank you for support solo Grady glory
to you
the president of the French Republic
foreign
[Music]
continue
solid the Democracy foreign
the protection of the democracy is
foreign
evidence
[Music]
is fundamentals
the Republic
ANS orientation
discrimination
[Music]
the France is determination Frontier
is
solidarity International
importance is
foreign
Ukraine
is sovereign
foreign
elaboration
mobilizations
Humanity
immediately
ready
Ukraine
[Music]
is foreign
refugee
is
Lucid
determination no
semi-democratic European
accordion
foreign
Universal
Mercy
till guests
the federal chancellor of Germany
is
foreign
thus soul to Oblivion at foreign
capacities
the whole part is foreign
Commission
Angeles
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
dear guests the president of the Council
of Ministers of the Italian republic
[Applause]
foreign
boy
secure
departure contact
s
associated
zelensky
grazia sharing Graziano
isando
look right
now
determination
libero
party
liberta
TI Integrity
democracia is
Europe
fundamentally
Edition
professional
foreign
umana
Europa foreign
Europa
foreign
[Applause]
minister of the United Kingdom
foreign
[Applause]
on the streets of Strasbourg in 1949
Winston Churchill one of the founding
fathers of this Council
spoke about Legend
he was talking about what makes our
continent so successful
the values of freedom
democracy and the rule of law
The Same Spirit we've seen again and
again
that led Vacaville to broadcast his
messages of Freedom during the
suppression of the Prague spring
that brought down the Berlin Wall
and that leads Ukraine to defend its
sovereignty with such Valor inspiring us
to stand with them all
the Council of Europe has nurtured that
spirit for three quarters of a century
and it must do so again now
because today we are facing the greatest
threat to democracy and the rule of law
on our continent since before the Treaty
of London was signed
with Russia waging a war of aggression
on European soil and China growing in
assertiveness
the world is becoming more contested and
more volatile
the challenge to our values is growing
and the moment to push back is now
democracies like ours must build
resilience so that we can out cooperate
and out-compete those who drive
instability
that's why we're working so closely with
our friends across Europe
through the G7 NATO The Joint
expeditionary Force the European
political community and with a welcome
new tone in our relations with the
European Union
friends the United Kingdom may have left
the EU but we have not left Europe we
remain a proud European nation
and we must work together to defend the
values we all hold so dear
the Council of Europe with its huge
reach has such a vital role to play
and we need to think about how this
Council should react to the realities of
today
we showed great purpose in expelling
Russia last year acting decisively
together within days of the invasion
let's bring that dynamism to the issues
before us now
and let's send a message from this Hall
loud and clear that we will stand by
Ukraine for as long as it takes
we will hold Russia accountable
for the horrendous war crimes that have
been committed
and we must also learn the lessons of
this war
by being prepared to confront threats to
our societies before they become too big
to deal with
that includes acting on cyber security
and AI
and it means tackling illegal migration
the moral case for Action is clear
we can't just sit back and watch as
criminal gangs profiteer on people's
misery
illegal migration exploits the most
vulnerable
it risks crowding out those with a
genuine case for Asylum
and it strains the trust that our
citizens have not just in our domestic
borders but in the International System
and that's why so many of us are already
acting at the national level
and why we need to do more to cooperate
across borders and across jurisdictions
to end illegal migration and stop the
boats
the council already plays a vital role
but I urge leaders to consider how we
can go further
because we know what we can achieve
together
just look at this council's
extraordinary Legacy
protecting human rights abolishing the
death penalty in Europe supporting media
freedom and championing democracy across
Central and Eastern Europe after the
Cold War
so let's take heart from that
and keep rising to the many challenges
before us
true to our enduring values and certain
that as Churchill went on to tell the
strasbour crowd
the dangers before us are great
but great too is our strength
thank you
[Applause]
dear guests
the president of the Republic of Poland
[Applause]
Excellence is
ladies and gentlemen
the Council of Europe was established at
a very special time
and with a very concrete goal
it was a moment when the whole world and
European particular
was just overcoming the horrors of the
war
the old world was set on fire by
imperialism and National egoisms
they implied among others lack of
respect for freedom of citizens the
value of human life the ruler of Law and
democracy
the Council of Europe was set up to
defend those very values
they unite us and provide the foundation
for our unique community
we need to bear in mind when we start
our discussion today
we are a community of values and it's
our duty to defend them
ladies and gentlemen
the Summits of the Council of Europe do
not take place every year
neither do they take place on a regular
basis
they are held at crucial and historic
moments which require a deeper
reflection the values that underpin our
organization
especially the first summit in Vienna
in 1993
in October
soon after the fall of the iron carton
and the third Summit in Warsaw in 2005
which followed the biggest enlargement
of the European Union to place moments
of strategic importance for the future
of Europe
this is the case also today
Unfortunately The Summit in Reykjavik is
taking place at the time of the largest
attack on Democratic Values since the
fall of totalitarian regimes
on the old continent
with its invasion of Ukraine Russia
wants not only to destroy the country
it also wants to revise all the values
which form the basis of the Council of
Europe
let us remember that Putin's plan
includes
in its wider context the construction of
a different order
an order based on values contrary to
ours
in such a world democracy becomes an
empty notion
what matters is just naked Force human
rights are only a facade
as every citizen can be sentenced to
tens of years in a penal colony will
lose their life for any reason
all of us here must be fully aware of
this
at previous times our countries debated
on the directions of development after
the spectacular triumphs of democracy
today we are meeting at the critical
moment
when Russia remembered state of the
Council of Europe just a year ago
together with its Vasa lukashenko is
attacking the whole free world
we must not yield to that we have to be
even stronger and more united
let's use this moment to boost our
identity and unity
we have an opportunity to express
it and the common thing debates
that's why
the Declaration
which we are going to adopt here is so
crucial
it confirms first of all our joint
responsibility and determination to
support Ukraine as long as it takes
an issue of equal importance
will be the one to establish the
register of Damages inflicted on Ukraine
by the Russian aggression
it's an important step to call to
account those guilty of crimes committed
in Ukraine
crimes have to be accounted for
it's of key importance to compensate the
victims and their loved ones
but it's also a precondition for peace
and stability in future
ladies and gentlemen in conclusion let
me remind The Words which I said on many
occasions before
today it's Ukraine who sheds its blood
and gives lives in the name of the
values which underpin our identity
we the Free World
must be determined to support them in
this fight
without such support all our
declarations will remain void thank you
[Applause]
dear guests
the president of the European Commission
[Applause]
prime minister dear Katrin first of all
thank you so much for hosting us in this
Lively and vibrant city of Reykjavik
presidents and prime ministers Secretary
General dear colleagues ladies and
gentlemen
today war is back in Europe
but for many ukrainians
this conflict began already 10 years ago
it began when peaceful protesters
just waving the European flags and
maidan square
were shot dead by snipers
it began with Russia's first invasion of
Crimea and donbass
in 2014.
Saha of Prize winner
Alexandra matvichuk is one of these
ukrainians she started documenting human
rights violations
by the regime and by Russian troops
already a decade ago
she spent countless nights
listening to the victims and to their
families
Alexandra and her friends
at the Ukrainian Center for civil
liberties have never stopped fighting
for democracy
for human rights
for a free and independent Ukraine
for over 10 long years
and that's why
they were awarded the Nobel Peace price
As We Gather here in Iceland
allow me to quote
Alexandra's words
she said
it is to stop Ukraine's progress
towards genuine democracy
that Russia invaded
it is not NATO that put in fears it is
democracy
this is a war of values
Russia is fighting against the values
that are Europe's Hallmark
and Europe must take responsibility
end of quote
she is so right
Ukraine is fighting for the values we
believe in and we hold so dearly
and I'm so grateful that we are united
in protecting peace and promoting
democracy
because this is the very reason why the
Council of Europe was created
and this is what brings us here today
as Russia wages war against democracy
itself
Europe is United
and standing up for Ukraine
this is our commitment
rightly so
the Ukrainian people are demanding
accountability for Russia's war crimes
the shelling of Civilian homes
the executions in Cold Blood
the Abduction of children from their
families
over nineteen thousand children have
been stolen torn away from their
families this is what the summit of
Iceland should focus on
this is why we are here to discuss these
topics it is important for ukrainians
today
because the prospect of accountability
can already deter Russian soldiers from
committing new war crimes
but it is also important for the future
because only Justice can be the
foundation of lasting peace in Ukraine
a just peace
ladies and gentlemen
since the creation of the Council of
Europe
our continent has embarked on a journey
towards democracy
we rebuild not only our cities
but also the morale foundations
of Europe
we have put freedom
equality
and solidarity
at the heart of our societies
our journey has continued as more and
more European countries moved from
dictatorship
to democracy
and that Journey continues today
it continues inside our countries
whenever human rights and the rule of
law are challenged
continues in Ukraine
and in every place where people are
taking to the streets and waving the
flag of our common values
and today
we recommit to these values
we will do everything possible
so that Ukraine wins the peace
a just peace
and we will do nothing about Ukraine
without Ukraine
this is why we strongly support
Ukraine's peace formula
the Ukrainian peace formula
is the foundation of their path towards
peace
and that is why
I Call On Us
at this Summit to really rally behind
this peace formula
in these testing times
it is so important that we all join
forces
the ukrainians are fighting for
democracy and for freedom
it is our common fight
and we stand by their side for as long
as it takes
Slava Ukrainian Long Live Europe
[Applause]
dear guests the Secretary General of the
Council of Europe
[Applause]
excellence
foreign
organizations
controller
final terrible
the Supreme
Ave
this Summit
forms part
of our response
you can answer Russia's spiral of
descent by lifting Europa
and ensuring the peace and Democratic
security that come when rights are
respected
so I invite you to recommit to the
organization's values and standards
not just in words
but by Deeds
the implementation of the European
convention on human rights the
unconditional execution of the Court's
final judgments and support for Ukraine
ensuring accountability for Russia's
Crimes by endorsing a register of damage
and tackling the outrageous Abduction of
Ukrainian children by Russia
you can take action to reverse the
Democratic backsliding and apply our
Timeless standards to contemporary
challenges such as artificial
intelligence and climate change
ladies and gentlemen
Europe faces a choice
let our standards fail
and see Europe go backwards into the
wild or reinvest in what has brought us
so much good
now is the time to set that course for
the benefit of all Europeans
[Applause]
[Music]
is
foreign
[Music]
thank you
Your Excellence is ladies and gentlemen
it is my immense honor to be here today
to play for you a very special song
a song that has United the Icelandic
people in times of happiness and in
times of grief
a song that was written some hundred
years ago
one of the first composers of Iceland a
song that like all great art belongs not
to a nation but to All Nations
the song is called Ave Maria it is a
prayer and today's performance is
dedicated to the people of Ukraine an
Icelandic prayer for peace and for
justice in Europe thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
thank you vegan because I think every
Icelander cries when we hear this song
dear colleagues thank you for your
remarks
and thank you all for being here
and make this moment a meaningful moment
for the future of Europe
and now we will get to work thank you
all
[Applause]